good afternoon this is sky news today
was thought that breaking news another
616 deaths have been recorded at
hospitals across the UK let's turn to
our health correspondent 'she's Joshi
whose life was in the news room as she
shared this pleasure of these figures
for us the figures are for a 24-hour
period across the UK there's always a
lag between the the numbers collected
individually nation by nation and the
number that's been put out by the
Department of Health and Social Care
this time on a daily basis it relates to
a 24 hour period from 5:00 p.m. the
previous day to yesterday and and then
released and then collated and released
today so that's a figure over the last
24 hours not not including today the
number has gone up by 616 more deaths
sadly across all four nations of the UK
bringing the total to 18,000 738 and
remember column then this is a very
important thing to remember is that this
figure does not reflect deaths outside
hospital these are deaths which have
taken place in a hospital where people
or patients have been tested for
coronavirus say that figure the true
figure for the UK according to some
experts could be up to 40% higher
according to the modelling and the
trajectory of the the figures released
by the Office for National Statistics
which does look at Kerr's deaths in care
home if I can sort of give you an
overview of what's happened in England
this week and that might help some
people to understand where the trend for
the the deaths occurring in England
certainly will will will give you an
indication of what we're doing and what
we're seeing in terms of the much wider
picture of course each death is a
tragedy for every family that is having
to grieve for a loved one but the on
Monday we had 430 people who had died in
England now that number is the lowest
this week and that's because of the lag
in collecting figures on a weekend then
it jumped up to 778 on the Tuesday and
that's because we have now caught up
with a weekend line and then 665
yesterday and then down to 500
14 at suddely is 514 people who have
died that on its own is a very very
large number and some people who have
been listening to the the daily press
conferences given out at Downing Street
by the health secretary he said this
week that we've probably seen the figure
or the number plateau and and/or people
reach its peak and then we would see a
plateau what he means when he says
reaching its peak it doesn't mean that
will suddenly stop at the number of
deaths and then it it just drops away
completely it means with this climb
we've seen on this graph the way it's
been plotted and it reaches a high but
to come down on the other side of that
you still have a very large number of
deaths in their hundreds until we're
finally out of this pandemic
she's thanks very much